okay Peter Julia pierpon from Tsinghua
news of China this has been an
extraordinary ride for you and
apparently you didn't originally want to
do the role where'd you hear that
everybody says that's nonsense
no how does that get rumor get started
no I I originally didn't want to do that
well no I had some concerns
maybe it's filtered down into some sort
of rumor that I didn't want to do it but
when I met Dave and Dan for the first
time with Carolyn Strauss another
producer on the show if so many years
ago
in Los Angeles here they told me about
it briefly and then I before I met them
and I came in with some concerns about
this genre having seen many many pieces
because I wasn't familiar with the books
so I wasn't familiar with the complexity
of Tyrion at that point because
unfortunately before this character many
times people my size weren't complicated
enough for me to be interested in doing
it I had done it one or two times before
and sort of didn't you know grabbed me
but they relieved my concerns very
quickly in the back road and the leaders
congratulations it's kind of a far
traveled journey you've had from the
station agent you know the last time I
spoke with you you were just you were
just doing indie films and you were
perfectly happy doing indie films and
now you're in one of the most successful
television programs of all time
bittersweet to find out it was coming to
an end of course yeah we had I had my
last day on set back in July of this
year just two months ago now a little
over two months ago and it was very sad
it's not only a great TV show to be a
part of but it was in an enormous family
to be a part of and I'm sure you've
heard that before from actors but in
this case I was far from home I live in
New York and we shot the show over in
Europe so many times I had to stay there
and I wasn't able to go home on the
weekends and so I really
developed deep roots in the community of
Ireland and in some of the other
countries we shot in so it was
definitely hard to say goodbye because I
wasn't saying goodbye just to the the
show I was saying goodbye to a life over
there and how do you top this how do I
top Game of Thrones or winning an Emmy
or everything no I
you just keep searching hoping that the
next writer you come across is equally
as talented as David Benioff and Dan
Weiss
Thank You mr. Dinklage congratulations
to you I'm Tom Beck doesn't matter hey
I'm nothing to look at anyway hey watch
that this the show had become so popular
so fast it's a major motion picture
every week yeah
even with its popularity I know that
didn't surprise a lot of people as it
began to grow but has anything in that
process surprised you about what about
the popularity on the bout the growth of
it about where it went yeah it's always
very surprising often times the things I
love being a part of movies I make that
I'm very proud of nobody ends up seeing
because they're indie movies and that we
struggled to find audiences for them but
this this had that same feeling but on a
grander scale and and I absolutely
adored this character and the stories we
were telling so it it's it's just so
beautiful when when when other people
feel the same thing you do last question
here on the right
hi there Peter Angela Bishop from
Network Ten Australia g'day hello you
came down under a few years ago to make
one of your films I love you too with
Pete Hillier and I thought it was
magical and now that Game of Thrones is
done would you consider coming back and
got another one on my way on your way I
love that man you know that man yeah I
do so we could get you back down under
in a flash any time okay you're gonna
promise yes I I I will commit to that
promise
thank you Peter congratulate us thank
you
you
[Music]